[Music]
so
great
[Music]
so
okay
sup floor game
it's a bit low volume bing bong
it's been glitchy too
just setting up should be ready in a
minute
how y'all doing let's get exciting
smash like for a new let's play let's go
hey that's quite live i like that
so
let me make sure i don't have to do this
mid
gameplay
oh i gotta change reticle color
it's gotta be red obviously
ray tracing
mm-hmm
no
okay we got some bonuses
uh yeah this is what i was looking for
uh obviously we we played a seven but i
mean that was years ago
so they give you this recap that i
thought why not when i go through
i i don't remember that much gonna be
honest there was a crazy family
where to start
my name it's ethan
it's been three years since everything
happened at the baker house yeah
literally
i was looking for my wife who that's
right
i got an email from her
she told me to come get her and of
course that's how i ended up in the
middle of nowhere louisiana
that's sorry rip if you're living in
louisiana i found mia being held captive
in a dark basement
she wasn't thinking right
she attacked me like some kind of wild
animal
later on i found out that she was
infected by a special kind of mold
got all mold i gotta make sure i'm
watching can you find an antidote
a vaccine anything same bro
the people who lived there were already
infected
what was that i remember him wasn't
human
the source of the infection was a buyer
weapon that looked like a little girl
oh right was evelyn
i fought the [ __ ] up family and was
able to treat me as symptoms with a
serum
that was a cool bus
oh yeah that's redfield and his soldier
buddy showed up and saved the both of us
i thought for sure there was good enough
gonna be dlc
or something because i really don't want
to talk about what happened anymore
the ending was a bit uh strange like
they were setting something up
sorry for talking all right there we go
all right good reminder
we went to spooky house spooky stuff
happened
uh oh i
if i played on pc maybe honestly i'm so
village of shadows so bad with council
a young girl went with her mother to
pick berries for her father
who was hard at work but the forest
greeted them with a dark
cold silence very different
yet determined to find the berries the
rasco broke free from mother's grasp and
vanished into the trees
mothers worried cries faded fast as the
girl ran on
over vine and under branch and into the
forest deep
feeling strange eyes upon her the girl
recalled mother's scary bedtime tales
and her throat became bone dry
then the pat lord appeared he greeted
her warmly
and bit his own wing come chill
quench your thirst he said so she drank
the thick
dark blood and smiled with you oh
vampire mommy backstory
graveyard menacing storm clouds loomed
and the air turned bitingly cold the
girl was shivering in her thin clothes
then a dark weaver appeared and with a
clip
of his fingers crafted mist into a
beautiful dress
come child warm yourself he coaxed
so show homie yourself and smiled with
joy
across waters deep and ominous she went
hoping a boat she found would carry her
home
but hunger's grip tightened and her
heart grew heavy
then the fish king appeared and offered
one of his
many fins come child eat your
fill so the girl ate and smiled with joy
once more
continuing on she soon entered the
forest's
dark heart then an iron steed appeared
bearing a beautiful golden gear
the creature said nothing as the girl
approached and snatched
what she thought was another gift oh no
no
the horse grew angry and summoned the
other monsters
[Music]
you got greedy girl killed the girl's
heart as the wild wind rose around the
beast
a witch appeared dark yet regal
this is so unlike any resident evil
style
but more you took she snarled so more in
turn is due
in a blink the girl was trapped inside a
mirror
that's a that's a fake baby she's asleep
what is with the creepy story she's only
six months old
woman at the store said it was
traditional
a local tale besides
rose doesn't seem to mind because she
doesn't understand it
thank god we moved to where i wouldn't
have to deal with any of that remember
there's nothing wrong with my memory
all right baby just being paranoid it's
not
never mind i'm sorry but i'm not
paranoid i'm just
cautious then go cautiously take your
daughter to bed
[ __ ] dead simp simulator over here
[ __ ]
and now we get to play holding a baby
all right which one do i throw it with
it's okay rose your mother doesn't want
to remember it i can't blame her
our two to throw how's his work
did you say something nothing i'll put
her down
i'll put her down all right oh we got to
change diapers
finally
this is weird
should we dip her in the sauce smash
like if you want her dipped in the sauce
all right she put it said put her
i'm just checking the place out you know
it's kind of neat unexpected but you
know
exactly once things warm up we can go
for a walk
gotta check the drawers should we put it
in the drawer
smash like if you want to put her in the
drawer shut up
shut up i don't scream they're there
what's wrong with it that book's too
scary for you
yeah your mom's a psychopath
all right
oh what is this baby your mama and i
love this song so much
all right that way or this way
i don't know almost there honey i don't
know my own house
this is weird dude all right here we go
this is your room right
this is what you play with you're not
gonna have a playstation
cringe bro all right put me down there
you go sweetheart
don't you worry i'll be right downstairs
daddy won't let those weird fairytale
monsters get you
okay the baby's cursed understood
oh it all right we can check around a
little bit
check our emails
mia and i had another fight i
accidentally mentioned what happened
three years ago and she blew up at me
we finally settled down in our new life
in europe
we're in transylvania bros
it can bring rose up properly but i
still feel like a part of me is trapped
in that hell hole
back in los angeles another doesn't like
to talk about it
but can we really just forget everything
and pretend it didn't happen
shouldn't we face what happened there
mia needs therapy dude
so we can live our lives with rose
without it hanging over our heads
we all heard that much at least i know
mia knows this too
she wouldn't have exploded like that at
the hospital if she didn't care
sheesh all right
the european medical listen uh-huh
asian is good that's good
rose is fine well you didn't know this
you just read that paper rose's favorite
toy
gun survivalist heavy fire i know i have
to really out to get you
bro you're gonna have to struggle
getting guns in europe bro this ain't
[Laughter]
america
oh they copied our wedding photo with
the veil
oh my god
yeah nah i'm okay
i don't need to look at baby photos i
want to shoot things
are we doing over here all right let's
go downstairs
i'm gonna check that out but i don't
really care
it's cool though looks great
i will keep checking her on the camera
cool boo
whenever i am okay i'm sleeping like uh
well like a baby hmm that smells good
what's that oh hands off mister it's
choba de la gum
it's a local recipe wow you've gone full
native haven't you
local wine too but if you're gonna keep
sulking all evening
maybe you shouldn't have any touch
you really have to stop worrying
it's just finding you in louisiana the
pregnancy
chris moving us here military training
it all happened so fast
you know well at least we're all
together
you me rose
now everything's gone seriously i think
we can just forget about what happened
in louisiana
it happened so long ago yeah i don't
understand why you are so
mia get down
wow someone just did me a favor gotcha
was obnoxious
mia oh god
chris what the hell sorry ether
no i think i think she's dead
actress
uh what the heck bro you just shot my
wife like 50 times
go move
oh not the baby all clear rose
what the hell you doing with my daughter
package secured
sir package take him away
get your hands off her ethan no
oh
well then kill me for some reason
what's all this saying
no problem we'll be there
that was the doc doc oh she's alive
looks nice
hey now think positively all right
we talked about this i know
we hardly talk about anything else
i keep telling you it's not rose that
i'm worried about
well then what are you worried about
yeah look
she's gonna be fine i just know it what
else matters
what are you talking about is there
something you're not telling me
come on talk to me
[Music]
jesus
what the [ __ ] happened what are you
talking about
where's chris redfield and rose
we're clearly not secure bruh [ __ ]
what the hell happened to you
oh cool when it's not i did say when it
gets water
warmer we can go outside all right cool
uh guys
no spoilers in the chat
you will get banned eliminate
target recover body secure me
and baby um
at least two well they should have gone
with three right
[ __ ] it's so dark
my god damn
is that first
next gen game i'll probably do a full
playthrough
it's really neat
like look at these branches like the
quality of the texture right
wow right this is next-gen right here
i'm talking about it it does look good
i'm just
i'm just working
you guys expecting a jump scare
i'm not so sure anything out there
okie dokey
i'm just trying to follow these tracks
here
raising my arse all right
press x to crouch no all right
gonna need a tetanus shot
like i walked the wrong way or is it
here get it
oh lumber is there an axe or something
no
oh oh no
mr crow this is so sad
it was like a father to me how could you
not mrs crow now you really pissed me oh
the whole family
oh [ __ ] how you doing who hangs a crow
oh bro you all got hung by the neckaroo
oh i'm so sorry bro that's [ __ ] up
dude ooh could this be the witch
what was it it was a force
you're gonna be fine you're gonna be
fine we're gonna send our rescue team
i'll be right back okay
i'm just gonna go you're being loud and
annoying all right
none of these other crows are yelling
oh my gosh me me me me
so there are jump scares my god
a lot of branches here we go here's
something
this looks safe walking over
a pond or something
sounded like a printer
bro if your printer sounds like that you
gotta get a new one man
i'm looking for like a weapon or
something surely there should be
a broom no i want the broom
damn it
barrels what are you doing here
right there's got to be a gun here
oh wait we're not in america [ __ ] all
right there's got to be a knife here
oh road
and a brush
all right checking that out
check that the water's running always
gotta check that any house
nice boots i enter i gotta check if the
waters
okie dokie
don't think we're alone in here let's
check the closet
[Music]
should i just try and get help like what
is my goal here
find mia then by the baby i guess i'm
capable you know
can you read what books are not really
oh maybe we can uh pick this up no
hey mr fox i didn't check here obviously
hey mr mooch i thought i'm all right
cool english breakfast right there
yummy yummy
more dead plants sweet
zoom and turn
it's dark jesus
okay
that's gonna say boot what are you doing
here planks just falling
i don't know where
[ __ ] is it me or this is not scary at
all
like right
hey so cute room at last
we meet you try to hide from me
all right let's check this out
you okay you okay boat
you're right
all right i guess something's upstairs
so we gotta check it out right
so it sounded spanish her local recipe i
wasn't sure
are we in spain what other country
sounds kind of spanish in europe i don't
know
maybe portugal they have a bunch of
weird castles in portugal
all right who's up there mr fox
ah we're barricaded on pushy pushy
what's in all this
that's a good question it's called the
beginning i'm curious about the story
uh ah barrel obviously obviously
pewdiepie reference in resident evil 8
cannot believe it
all right we're heading out it's
brighter now
are we done here let's see are there any
other tracks
no just this way
yeah sun went up
oh all right we're running now
now times are wasting
epic viewing coming
that's pretty i like that
[Music]
where are we sure
what the [ __ ] is that romanian
we gotta find michael
that looks sick
love it okay we go down here
it's cool i like the theme of vampires
why does romanian sound somewhat so
um mexican
what's it ah they kill the horse [ __ ]
your game
find them i'll avenge you cement i mean
you're again
you're smen my brain man
ah [ __ ] i'll avenge you eggs
they got bleach
should we follow that yeah let's go for
it hey how you doing
where the [ __ ] did that go that made no
sense
oh it needs some kind of other item
like a lever or something let's check
the toilet always
any levers in here a but
who drew a butt on the box that's
disgusting what's wrong with romanians
all right love her
do not air but bro
do we have any reason to go to the
castle yet like
is this there we're looking for our wife
and our baby right now my wife is dead
all right let's see what you can find
here
okay
here we go nice plumbing in romania
i respect it i do i really do
can't seem to find oh that's random i
remember the monk
do i have motion blur on
i feel like my eyes get strained trying
to turn and [ __ ]
am i the only one
so wonky movement camera acceleration
let's try that
i'll make it bigger maybe that helps
oh i always gotta check the toilet
dammit
okay brows what are we doing here we
need to find the labyrinth
i don't remember where we came from this
kind of
all right we have not been here what up
goats what happened
it happens normal no more romanian
tradition
don't judge it all right it's what they
do here we go
locked due to missing homeowner is that
romanian
romanian bros translate i mean i know
what it says
baby oh
that's
some force could break it does that mean
i can punch
oh open my inventory uh
uh-huh some force that means we're gonna
find something to defend our subway
there it is nice boom what up knife how
you doing
so we can attack with r2 and that's it
no r1
boom decent thing and
how do we use it
i don't know okay
did they just run out of the house
how many of you think we can break the
soup
disappointed not not my next gen
[Music]
okay we're definitely gonna run it this
is the classic right as soon as you get
a weapon in the game it's like
okay now now something will attack you i
think that's why
it wasn't scary in the beginning because
you know they're not going to do
anything
all right we got to find another way out
huh
until you get the weapon
uh behind the curtains
[Music]
no no i'm friendly friendly
who are you who sent you nobody
there was an accident down the road
it's jacksepticeye top of the morning to
you
oh my god it is
oh no
they're coming who is what the hell was
that
do you have a gun you know what you got
it i have a gun
no why would i
oh nice yeah yeah yeah
there are above us
all right
oh [ __ ] hey are you listening
hey oh no give me the shotgun
damn it jack safety guy
all right this is when you camped
i can't see [ __ ] oh hey how you doing
i'm dead buddy
wait there's more
mamma mia are we doing down here
you all right mate better get crack
cracking in my
ah bruh jesus christ
i hope jack didn't die hell is wrong
with this place
he's gonna come back i know it hey
another one how you doing
you're right mate oh somebody's moving
there
y'all see it are we
oh it's a vampire
all right do i get to shoot him ah my
finger
the rooney was that
[Applause]
no i have a gun all right
here we go let me let me just shoot you
in the head
there we go
oh i got a card
all right all right let's try that again
i
don't you
how are you alive
you then
nice it's so weird because the control
the controller have the thing where
you have to press hard on it it feels so
strange like i want to click but it's
like
you have to pull a little bit now it's
easy again but when you have the gun up
you have to like pull it it's kind of
cool i'm not used to it though
forgot about that that's like the next
gen controller thingy
all right what are we cooking boys snow
my favorite dish
family photo can't use that here
all right let's check the house out a
little bit more
maybe jack spit actually has some uh
i want his gun to be honest
all right oh
yo mini shovel i could use that
all right let's use the bolt cutter
whoa it's very pretty
i like it ah
all right stop this now
they're fast
[Applause]
nothing all right oh hang on
nice that means going to be another
fight
no
are we doing up here mate
hey we're barricaded thanks sparrow
you're the best
did we avoid a fight bro is this a
staircase get over yourself let's go
it's still mine [ __ ] it's still miami
ken bloon i knew
is he in no
where are they
where am i supposed to go
i'm sorry am i missing something obvious
well we can camp here
what is happening
guys chill i can't think
all right i guess i have to go down
there we go
that's all right nice all right
i don't know if i want to waste ammo
there we go he's waiting for you
all right all right let me just head
show you
no
i'm not gonna die on the first level
it's nice hold up bro let me disinfect
this
oops thank you
i totally blocked
the controls are so wonky
bro just send stuff thank you
oh i got some money
can i go here
is it over
yeah we did it
it's so like it's like you're drunk when
you aim
to louise's house near the fields
survivors
all right mate
oh i forgot about our finger
i kind of hate the trigger thing it's so
like i want to shoot but you have to
really pull and then you
change your aim by the time you want to
trigger
i know it's like resident evil it's not
supposed to be like
hey guys
oh hold on
don't think i'm supposed to fight these
guys
oh give me that okay
they're behind me aren't they
i ain't going down there
it's only have two shots in it what the
[ __ ]
all right
okay let's keep running
down here yeah probably
hey guys what's up so there's explosive
there
there's no end to them
is this a dead end yeah
are we doing here fellas
out of my way jose
maybe here
i'm just going in circles man
oh i'm fine so you can craft ammo maybe
hold up fellas i'm just going in circles
all right let's try blowing them up then
oh scrap
did we go here no we didn't nice
hey let's go upstairs
oh bro they gotta chill out
oh we can camp here oh they're shooting
arrows
goddamn romanians
oh shoot
what's making that [ __ ] sound
oh big boy what the [ __ ]
all right romanian you got me
don't shoot me where am i supposed to go
all right let's try here player i'm not
supposed
romanians don't [ __ ] around i gave him
that man
ah yes i found it
[ __ ] that's all right i got this
i got this i got this
i'm so dead
there was a crate where i jumped off all
right let me try this
he's on my side
i'm having a bad day dude
all right come on let me live
guys chill
oh they got horses
was this one of those bits where you're
supposed to die like what is happening
[ __ ] dark souls character up in this
[ __ ]
romanian santa claus
[Applause]
i was like this is surprisingly
difficult for the beginning of a game
and then it's like oh you're supposed to
[ __ ] up
ah you're gonna have to treat that bro
oh that's kind of cute
i like how we moved away from louisiana
to avoid like
all this creepy [ __ ] right then we moved
to romania out of all [ __ ] places
right
next to like a haunted village a haunted
castle i'm like
[ __ ] we really [ __ ] oh nice i saved some
ammo that's good
how we doing here lady in life
and in death we give glory
uh hello you shouldn't be out here it's
not safe
what the hell hey can you hear me
hey granny it's you
the child's father child
hey wait do you mean rose is she here
yes she is in great danger
since mother miranda brought her to the
village we have fallen into
darkness what are you talking about the
monsters
the castle bell heralds danger
they're coming no wait
where's rose who's mother miranda the
bell
tolls first mama big mama coming
again
[Laughter]
[Music]
at least you know she shut the door for
us
hey granny you kind of locked me in here
granny plea
please i uh
i'm dang it all right let's save the
shot gun
i gotta get used to these [ __ ]
controls man
maybe
[Music]
yeah yeah
all right
are we doing in here
mr sean
i think i can break these nope
only the obvious boxes okay
now i haven't noticed the controller
vibrating in a cool way yet but i'm sure
it's gonna and if it does i'll
definitely tell you
all right so where should we go castle
dimitry
or ceremony sign so many fun options
oh i see we're back here
some kind of other item
uh we know you found some items but
not quite this one
oh [ __ ] castle bad
oh that was cool what is this
what we offer these goats
of warding to protect the people of the
village and his people and who break
them shall
feel mother miranda's right
forgive me for what i must do
cynic nice
[ __ ] ghosts
okay so we got to put our heads there
let's put the family photo there and the
other one all right let's check out the
ceremony site
oh is that over here
so did he let me examine her i did first
thing
this is locked
yep
could probably climb it but you know
don't want to
we got some apples and oranges
very nice oh gunpowder can i craft
anything
no no no
all right let me just go forward then
what about here neat
cozy
well that's a bit dramatic all right so
we got one of them
mummy mummy
it's captain jack sparrow as well nice
okay how do i uh
should disaster fall upon the village
seek out the crests
one is in the care of the church the
other end is in louise's house
so we gotta go to the church
it looks like we found the one in the
church actually we gotta go to louise's
house
which is a lot
okey dokey yeah we're definitely
ah safe station
all right where's this [ __ ] house
oh no can i hide
sun tzu always avoid a fight
yes
what's all this thing
nice
can we jump over here
we can't
uh that's annoying um
guess we gotta go around there you take
them out with a knife
i thought there would be a quick time
for me to kill you not the opposite what
the [ __ ] dude
that's fine we're fine he doesn't know
where i am
he has no idea where i am
bro bro i'm a swedish boy i'm lost in
romania i don't like it here
how the [ __ ] did you end up there
oh you made me waste one but i blocked
what the [ __ ] oh he can jump over
well so can i
just kill me i deserve to die honestly
you have to block way earlier
like you see my hands go up but it
doesn't block it
okay no no stealth kills apparently
oh yeah they were shocking ammo over
here
i want to waste them
just feels like whenever i aim it just
shoots up
all right let's avoid this guy
get out of here you're pissing me off
dude
we got this
[Music]
bye
nice
[Applause]
how are you still alive
thank you
hey now we can probably craft
sweet just dip myself feel all better
all right let's avoid the last one
you definitely saw me
[ __ ] all right we're gonna have to shock
him i don't like this either
how much [ __ ] help does this guy have
thank you thank you
he's dead close the door
please you could have helped they're so
annoying
what are you doing here
stay back please don't hurt us
whoa it's okay i'm not gonna hurt you
honestly i kind of feel like i see
normal people at last
have you seen any other survivors no
they're all in louise's house and she's
not answering in the gate is locked
quiet girl
he's an outsider
guess i'm not knife master 2021 [ __ ]
[ __ ] we're setting ducks in here can
your old man walk
no one of the monsters cut him he's lost
a lot of blood we have to get into
louise's house
there must be a way inside stay here
be quiet don't move until i get those
gates open
i could have crafted a lot of ammo what
the [ __ ]
here i'm saving this [ __ ]
yes
oh my gosh now you're all generous
what's that nothing happened oh okay
still missing that need some other kind
of item
like this
all right now i'm ready for a fight
there better be someone in here because
you're gonna die
yeah oh nice tiles
cream cream fluid oh kemp
it's like what do you use that for oh
another one
oh we got it no it's locked
is that it yeah
okay we need a screwdriver
isn't that right barrels
hello [ __ ] sake
yo they got pizza ovens in romania
i respect it how do i get inside
through the oven
through the window through them
okay i'm missing something obvious
what's going on here
the frick
oh it was something obvious
come on it's clear hurry
hurry
ah shut your mouth gramps
he's not used to relying on other people
i'm sorry
we'll be safe in here won't we
sharing out there that's for sure
hey do you know anything about what's
going on here
it doesn't make any sense mother miranda
has always protected us
nobody's answered
father
we have to get inside
this is like an average in romania for
you too
just hold on a bit longer papa
don't worry i got this you what you have
to do is you have to open the door hello
anybody home maybe a familiar voice
louisa open up it's me elena
stop shouting you'll draw the monsters
who's this a friend stay back it's
jacksepticeye
for god's sake julian let us in no
they'll smell the blood you'll endanger
us all
my father will die out here that's not
my problem what's going on
these people want to let a dying man
into our home come now these people
are our friends go on go inside come now
this way you're not from this village
uh no no this really sucks
julian go make yourself useful and check
the grounds
i said go
well if elena trusts you
then so do i come inside ethan
wait here i'll check on the others
oh
is there any clues i've been there and
i've been there
and i've been there this way sorry was i
snooping
i was hoping i could block her off
come inside the others are waiting
what the [ __ ] is this outsiders you're
going to get us all killed
guys anton
we were hello fine by ourselves please
ethan
take a seat we we took like two steps to
help them
is this they were literally next to the
entire village
all that's left there is no one left
a worthless invalid
a stupid whaling [ __ ]
and you you drag a bloody man and an
outsider in here like it's nothing and
expect to be all
safe there is no safe
every sorry bastard out there has been
ripped in half
but tomorrow
tomorrow we'll all be dead
just like a damn husband put a sock in
roxanna that's enough
but a sucking egg has protected my
family for generations
and drunk or not you are all welcome
and safe in here whatever
he seems nice tell me what the hell is
going on here we don't know
one day we were a quiet devout village
and the next
the monsters came and attacked us
and they they kept coming wait louisiana
where is your husband did they
no no he he is out there
he's dead somewhere for sure bro
you went to get help yes yes yes
that's it he he went to fetch help
let us pray for him
for all of us good idea come
gather
great ones hear our voice
together as one oh we're praying my bad
we call on thee within
at
mother mother miranda with the mommy
mousekers
the tea should be ready come help me
elena please
can't wait that prayer i've heard it
before there was an old woman near the
graveyard
give me that
a [ __ ] as crazy as a bag of rats
there is wisdom in her devotion though
and i hope it protected her as it shall
protect us
[Laughter]
what are you doing leonardo what's wrong
are you okay
oh
father don't stay back no let me go
[Applause]
i have a gun right i could probably save
them
shoot let me shoot all right
stop it stop it let him go
i said no
right you couldn't i
i'm so sorry father she wasted two
shotgun shots get out of here it wasn't
your father anymore
you did the right thing
[Applause]
elena elena no there's nothing you can
do
this entire place is collapsing
you couldn't save him he was already
gone leave me alone
no we're getting out of here together
all right new love interest
i gotta get out of here
romanian girl let's see how it is
we have the maiden friends okay so we
need the other crunch
okay are you following uh when there
must be some key or something
here somewhere a locking mechanism
um not here
definitely not here this place is going
to burn down soon you think we can see
the mirror
no shame
all right we got some wine we got some
nothing we got some more nothing
oh chuba there amanda
a local dish tradition
we're getting money where are we gonna
spend that take the screwdriver out of
the
key ring if you need it all right so
where would i hang my keys
gotta be here somewhere nice
effect key ring
where's the bloody keyring then
all right so we gotta examine it this is
uh
love it we got it hey
look while you were crying like a little
damn the fire's moving fast i
find the screwdriver all right you hear
me
let's start this guys
what are you thinking step back we can
bust out with this
i could start uh doing ubers around the
village
i'm sure the vampires need some
transport
all right let me try that again
are you all right what just happened let
me back up again
the fire there isn't any time ah we got
plenty of time
that's good because smoke usually goes
to the bottom
grab on right
sure
don't worry and try not to breathe in
the smoke
i know thank you ethan
you're kind i know i'm i hope your
family is safe
i give you great advice once we get out
of here maybe you'll get to meet hey try
not to breathe a lethal smoke
just a little pro tip for you come on
it'll hold
there that's our way out oh thank god
but what then the village is still full
of monsters
we can't fight them there's too many hey
hey don't talk like that we'll find a
safe house to put you in until i can
find my daughter
my hunch is she's in that old castle no
the place is full of nothing but blood
and death
and i don't want to be alone while
you're father
oh [ __ ] he's still alive that's not him
not anymore bro she you shot him twice
you shot him twice idiot did you forget
about that i'm sorry you gotta go
i'm going with mommy milkers anyway stay
there you're dead
honestly don't even care come on
give me your hands
bye bye save your daughter
elena don't give up
reach for me
why is everyone dying on me you kind of
didn't let everyone die in that room
let's get really you could have
you could have killed me too much
so she shot him twice with a shotgun
without hesitating right
and then he goes ah and she's like no
it's my papa i must die now
domain
this place is going mad
why the [ __ ] is this happening again
hey [ __ ]
ethan's having a rough time man
let's go back in guys elena are you okay
all right we have the screwware rooney
bang
okie dokie
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh it said hello
who was what was that
why did he sound like uh morty from rick
and morty
mother miranda
you okay though you okay though
that's a nice tractor that's an r400
it's very popular in europe
looks like it's in decent shape
condition we could ride this all the way
up to the tower
shoot
the r stands for really good 400 times
over
uh let's see so we're back here right no
wait we gotta go back
further
hold up where did we come from is it
here
yes death has visited them all
mm-hmm
yeah good one
there part two
all right i gotta go
right through the church got it oh we
could save here actually
[Music]
yes yes yes yes
um where was the door that was already
here
okay
guess this leads to the castle oh i was
hoping you could switch them around but
i guess not
oh wait which way does it go oh
i know it fits [ __ ]
thank you
that's a nice door
nothing but blood and death huh
let's go always got to look out for
that ammo you know
cool cozy honestly
oh barrels we meet again
huh and they're making wine
geez well well
didn't think anyone was left you must be
pretty tough huh
who the [ __ ] are you oh
you're not local or even better
ah we
cool
you're whining we're almost there
[Laughter]
his father gets going yeah
the man is of no real use to anyone else
and my daughters do
so love entertaining forms
furthermore oh what the frick are you
killing
where you mean you'll screw around
give them to me and i'll put on a show
that everybody can enjoy
so ghosh what do we care for bread and
circuses
the man thinks suffering is assured yeah
cause a man's dick is cut off in the
castle no no
no no we're not doing that
i've heard all your arguments some of
you were less persuasive than others but
i've made my decision heisenberg a man's
fate is in your hands
where the [ __ ] mother miranda i must
protest
heisenberg is but a child and his
devotion to you
is questionable give the mortal to me
and i will ensure he
you'll find your food somewhere else
quiet now
child adults are talking i'm the child
you're the one who's arguing with
miranda's decision responsibility if it
was
wealthy oh keep glory one day your head
will actually fit your ego
you might fight don't i get a singing
silence my decision is
[Music]
and now let the games begin okay
[Applause]
let's see
get ready
three
jesus christ that's right
run for your life uh-huh
oh left or right i guess i picked the
wrong one didn't they
ah never mind very nice
don't shoot don't shoot don't shoot it
hurts it hurts i don't like it
ah santa goddammit
how did i survive that
you're still alive
yeah i know i uh oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
that's fine honestly we just kicked this
down
no problem [ __ ]
gotta
nothing like fresh
he likes american ground beef at least
oh what jesus christ
that's right run for your life uh-huh i
was and then i didn't
the the wait all of this
very nice thank you
all right here comes santa
[ __ ] i broke it
i got it
sorry i'm gonna be here but i had to
sneeze and i got a bunch of slime
it's disgusting i'll be right back
all right
okay
now
oh my god
all right what do i miss
geez
uh skip
[Applause]
so this part was oh
doing squats for no reason all right let
me in guys
seriously my word
you truly are as strong as they say
thank you
so i jump down here and then i just died
but i guess i'm supposed to just run
right oh where am i supposed to go
gotta keep dollar and more entertainment
here it is
blonde soaked grand finale
nothing like fresh american ground beef
uh bro you already used that line
too
wait do those freaks have rows
oh i'm oh lay
is it true that that song my is that
romanian
my faith so lay style
oh no no that's not it
i need to know this
do you think they make a an easter egg
in this game if that's the case
do you think he's dead
a lot of traps here
[ __ ] how many traps do you need bro
sheesh
it is romanian
so all right
it's such a strange language you don't
hear very often
now it's all i can think about when i
hear it chumba delay
barrels all right
what does numa nume i mean no my new
money
what it mean though
did i walk here yeah i did
was there an option to go straight here
no
i'm missing something
ah yes
we made a gamers
ah almost there nice
oh
anyone has heard of the likes of you a
hero
searching for his daughter though i must
say
that castle arouses suspicion
yeah and so do you
i am but a humble merchant here
oh forgive my manners call me the duke
now to business weapons ammunition
healing salves how could anything you
desire
i can provide
bro what a lad welcome ethan
i've prepared a special present for you
oh
supply sort of gunsmith or duke's purse
everything has a price what is that a
crystal skull we did get one of those
earlier
that's worth 900 apparently [ __ ]
are these stuff i can sell
you want to buy that
yeah i'll sell it [ __ ] it ah
uh what is this
weapon oh that was part of the game
slaughtering things
nice oh that's so strange
it costs nothing see why i shouldn't buy
it
do you have enough firepower i can now
offer an expanded weapon modification
service ooh
let's upgrade our handgun first
apologies but i don't extend credit
ah we're not there yet okay
everything is quite expensive i would
just buy the free
free stuff
what is this
all right we're done here till next we
meet
can't wait what a guy i like him
yeah he is cute
i guess it's like a resident evil 4 what
do you buy
i never played it but i just know it's
so like iconic
okay rose be here
three daughters bella cassandra and
daniella uh
literally didn't ask what the hell
romanians are cringe
let's go here oh
it looks good i like the light on the
curtain how you doing
i got good aim now
take that back ah there's the door
all right all right all right we're in
the castle
this is great
okay so this is like a hub by sim right
so pretty
they sure a lot of details back in the
day like [ __ ]
oh my god everything's locked in this
joint
um where should we go we came do we come
from here
i think yes
what about this store then ah
oh oh
oh so much stuff nor stains
a craftsman of the late 19th century in
north stain
was branded a heretic in his homeland it
wanted the lions until he settled in a
remote village
norstein then created four labyrinth the
castle the house on the hill the
waterwheel
and the iron tower upon their completion
he put a gun to his temple
and took his own line each labyrinth is
unique and required some specially
crafted meatball i'm kidding
uh madame ball to operate each one i
wish contains crystallized
human remains which are said to be north
stain's four beloved wives
man had four wives sheesh
the labyrinths are their graves
cool i like that there's some crystal
[ __ ] here
oh don't tell me i was supposed to keep
that crystal skull
uh-huh
why is that moving
there's got to be some foreshadowing
stations
so there's a saving here but nothing
else
strange
that must mean we're coming back here
and that thing will unlock somewhere to
go through right
anyhow let's keep looking
did i check this one no i didn't my
stain is
lined up
dragon saudi day
[Laughter]
oh no it's a lame one
oh my dude my knees have gone through
way too much
this is [ __ ] up
oh bro you did not need to do both my
legs like that
mother i bring you fresh prey you are so
kind to me daughters
now this is what we've been waiting for
wow well ethan winters
you escaped my little brother's idiot
games did you
let's see how special you are
yes mother yes mother okay
very special some people say i'm super
special
are we
starting to go a little stale then let's
devour his man flesh quickly mother i am
the one who captured him
now now daughters first i must inform
mother miranda
but later well there will be enough
for everyone
hey god they love
[ __ ] ah we
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's all right i'll just hang around
so they cut my legs like i got an arrow
in my knee
i lost my fingers and then they hung me
through some meat grips
is this the demo by the way i never
played it
but i assume it's around this area all
right look around what do we got my
hands
i'm hanging oh that's
but maybe my left ah
you are crazy ethan
i would have torn the left one because
it's already fun
right
yeah yeah just pour some you're fine ah
that's good it'll heal
let's give it a 20 seconds
that's a nice plate
all right do i have my guns oh they
didn't take my guns
the [ __ ] they're gonna pay
class nice we got a [ __ ] glass over
here
do you think i can shoot the plane
it should crack right i think no i don't
think i can [ __ ] with this plate
next gen everyone what about the bottle
no that's a bottle
wow we live in the future
damn they must have spent a long time
designing all these details like
[ __ ] it's crazy
all right what about what about the
fruit can we cut the fruit
what about the tea cup
just curious what i got to work with you
know
do i need a key
oh oh
oh four shotgun
nice
what is this game from
raccoon
keep sneezing
having a good time
that's where we came from
what am i missing ah yes
city resident evil 2 of course
that's fun
it's cozy
hey boot you made it back man
all right can we break the pot yay
all right should we try crafting a
little bit we got some lightning
make more
[ __ ] i need to be so dramatic about it
this game is so extra
can i squeeze through
oh i should wear the armor right
all right we're getting a lot of stuff
here
it makes me think there's no pp uh what
are you saying
it's gonna say they don't have pp
protection in the medieval ages
oh we're back here nope we're not
yes we are
come on
all right what's this line no
we're back here have they taken rows
okay do you think the ring goes on one
of them
two of them three of them
well it would be here then it's probably
some faces
uh sorry only then you will be saved
whoa look at this
i'll take it
okay we're back here isn't there save
nearby here
they drink blood in the teapots
crazy
hey it pays off
there's so much hang on ammo now
gotta break everything now [ __ ] you
plant
sorry
examine the ring
where is it in my inventory
ah oh
it's looking right at me
[Music]
hey so so soul
[ __ ] pot
the eye gauges thing is that it
i just heard a door master angel's
blinded gays
i know we've been here because i [ __ ]
[ __ ] this place up
someone said to look under the cup i
figured i'd do it
all right let's go upstairs
yes love that
you know it's coming
watch you mister
ah come on
did my hand actually heal i haven't cut
open a man
in a while that's all right you're not
gonna let me string you up
slice your jugular and just watch
taking a live dead witch would you
prefer uh
let me think i'll get back to you on
that one
this is a boss
no yes i won thanks
that was unexpected
the winemaking techniques of castle
dimitriska
can be traced as far back as a 15th
century long before the current
occupants of the castle
alcina dimitriska uses his legendary yet
peculiar technique to enrich
the wine's flavor intensity and bestow
it with a thick bouquet
her best vintage is sang with virginies
i bet meaning maiden's blood
it is kept in a special ornate bottle
decorated with intricate silver
flowers
a special butter adorned with flowers
just some sort of [ __ ] clue
i guess i gotta put the bottle there
right
all right i got this got the bottle
there
let me get the bottle hey let me get the
bottle
we need some maiden's blood there maybe
all right maiden's block am i supposed
to look for a particular one
hello
am i a virgin can i use my own blood
athens a virgin we know this
right can the barrels be broken that's a
good question
nope they did look sturdy i'm not gonna
lie
why did that one vampire thing just come
to spook us
and then ditched you know i feel like i
looked in all the rooms
i didn't see any virgin no trace of
virginity
did i pick up a wine i don't think so no
bing bong hmm
virgin's blood hmm
yes yes
maybe in this there's
there's there's blood in here maybe
there's blood in the kettle and we could
pour it
and it unlocks a puzzle and then we can
all go home
this is locked yep okay
all right yeah you're probably right
there's something up there
we didn't fully examine this baby
ah [ __ ] [ __ ] not
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm fine
that's all right that's all right
that's all right
nope can't
kill a dead inside
june 9 1958 it was my first day working
at the castle today
i was most shocked to see the other
staff were all women
the mistress and her daughter were very
adamant that they wouldn't buy
it was quite peculiar
okay so two weeks three weeks later it's
been two weeks since oh
since i started working at the castle
and i'm a little afraid
another made adella made a mistake and
miss
daniella slash her face with a knife and
at night i can hear her wailing as if
ghosts roam the house i want to go home
i don't know what to do the young ladies
were complaining it was too hot and
stuffy during dinner
so i hope that we know just a crack shut
it now shut it now they all shrieked
that mean unison
sheesh i fear i may be taken down into
the cellar never to be seen
of again i don't know what to do
i don't know what it is i'm crazy that's
crazy i had to take a chat
but see
the music's popping though
oh yes
skirt
[Music]
what the [ __ ] ah follow the music
mummy mummy mummy mummy
we were so close to greatness
yeah better not make any noise oh
knife fruit thing they proved him
oh yeah we're looking for the wine
weren't we um
[Music]
what the [ __ ] are those
it makes sense the one is in the cellar
hmm i'm inside in the
whoa what a cool room
what's this for
the [ __ ] romania
what is the point of this room
ah trust in life
why is there's room here all right
they're all pointing
this mane
all right there's two of them and they
look identical
oh i look too close and immersion ruined
uh-huh okay
there has to be something
pushed the lantern
into the fire
whoa that's cool with my head
swing with some force
i could just stab it as long
[ __ ] you lantern
should i bring it oh no turn it on
thank you
so empty here like damn
torturing devices nice
love that one
what is it that's some sort of
eye drilling device nice big costume
while they this is like one of those
stretchy machines
at least they fed them
oh another lovely device
candidates arena michaela
michaela lewis ingrid rejects
oh lena didn't make it
this has something to do with virgin
blood or something
sorry barros you know i gotta try
find [ __ ] inside
all right
could use them what does it say here
indistinguishable all right they did
something epic down here clearly
ah [ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
definitely gonna be enemies down here
i'm fine with that
hello
all right [ __ ]
no
ah that's a lot of yet
all right guys
all right guys hey one night
watch where you swing that
all right you're the last one
thank you took a lot of ammo but
i think we did all right now
i need to find more ammo
nice are there more of them
yep
why not
whoa
all right how do i
guys
i wanna pipe one then
come on i want to blow them up believe
cassandra caused all this
mess yep
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
are we not bad
that tastes good all right
[Music]
i was leaving anyway
you're tonight's main dish oh
i'm a snack thanks
where are you going little one away from
you bed
stupid man thing
man thing move your hand
impertinent man what
my body is breaking die [ __ ]
it's not happening it's not happening i
don't like you
she then she's so very dead
that felt good i'm not gonna lie
it's fun i like it very
very good yes oh
[Music]
[ __ ] god man thing
she wanted my man thing what did i mean
i found the virgin blood wine
nice
now we gotta kill the other two of the
crazy ones and mommy milkers is all ours
[ __ ] are those dogs oh
that all right
oh recall compensate
ah oh
yes equip on the
vista
i guess we're safe as long as we're by
the windows right
ah yes okay so we're here now let me
look around a little bit more before we
go where we need to go
oh i broke the windows
cool that was unexpected i know you
could do that
okay upstairs
for green gamers
uh yeah we were hungry for a snack
that's why we hit the fingers
alright so is this where it was yes
nice virgin blood kind of what it tastes
not gonna oh it went away
[Music]
yes we use the key to get the key
to the courtyard bye
where's the space station
we should really save like it's been a
long time
it was on ground floor right
no i actually haven't saved so it would
be really good if we
don't do this right now
all right i can hurt this [ __ ] here
all right you wanna fight me now
didn't think so
all right
break all the windows break all the bus
well i guess we're not saving
oh yes
really pretty
okay we need uh something there
that's fine more time to kill vases
this is definitely not yet there's some
light over here so
and there this should be open
oh mommy mommy mommy i'm here
okay
i'm coming i'm coming
hey we're gonna have some cash later on
buckaroonies
i like doing that i don't know what that
says about me this is a door
no that's a wall what
have you done to my daughter
i'm here mom
oh a man
what is that left no that [ __ ]
which one do i press for the map
ah the middle one okay
we're in hall of able
look for rose in the castle that's our
quest okay
hello yo they got a
bath don't mind if i do oh it's blood
isn't it
that's [ __ ] up y'all [ __ ] up
women are blind to male advances but the
poor
shall take their chances to give their
lord their bounties
sown so that soon the wind the wine may
flow
if i ruin that don't flow at all
can i break
and your mother is a hoe
i thought it would be locked
oops nothing in here
no no no
ah yes
yes yes
oh that end
that ass that has today
hello how are you
fine thank you oh
all right so how do i know
can i move this as well yeah
move them how is it just looking over
there
nothing like a statue puzzle
i did it
women are blind to male advances but the
poor shall take their chances
give their lord their bounty zone so
that
women are blind to male advances okay
these are my
male is this male advances
but the poor shall take their chances so
they can look at him
to give their lord
it doesn't really tell me
doesn't really tell me that much
so the women look away from the men
right
and the guy is looking at the man
i can't turn it anymore
it's literally two two ways
i think this is right is she poor
the poor will take their chances
i'm missing something what am i lying to
me then
okay
could it be
that this one is wrong
ah yeah
yes so smart
hey very good in the basement
oh go time sorry go
i hope there's an achievement for
killing all of them because i definitely
will
and all buckets
what the hell oh this shocks you but not
everything else we've been through
dude we have so much ammo there holy
[ __ ]
this is wine
did you see me but here i am
scraps right
take it past here
all right are they in the water i smell
the jump scare
uh hello take the corners
where are they
hey there you are
all right you're gonna have to die for
that you know that right
stop wiggling your [ __ ] head
suddenly no one
oh another one where
where
ah
nice
[ __ ] man
i don't want to get hit by that
all right nice
why don't i t honestly why don't i take
their weapon
oh they're so annoying
let's make him count boy
i'm a wee bit lost at the minute
we came through here yeah
there's something there
all right we came here
and then okay
here we go where was it here we go
it's a bit late to barricade now right
yeah i'm scared for sure
there it is
ah what i'm hitting that
nice saw it coming
i like this place
i don't like this place
i might have to do this
[Music]
[ __ ] there we go
nice
all right all right all right all right
all right all right all right
all right i shot this
it would suck to run out of hammer not
gonna lie bros
ah ah yes
all right knife time
whoa whoa cool
i like that nice
off we go
all right we're out of that hellhole i
like the game
it's kind of cool
it's fun
ah shave station
[Music]
that's perfect because i kind of have to
end it there see you tomorrow
with another episode
thanks for watching hope you guys look
forward for more
and have a great day yes
see you tomorrow same time